foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program and we thank you for joining us
for taking a little a little time out of
what no doubt is a very busy day to sit
with us and to hear what God has blessed
us to offer to you this is as we said
the Bible question and answer program my
name is C.A Murray and I'm in the
company of Pastor David Salazar and
Pastor Stephen Bohr
fellow Travelers on the road to glory
and fellow students of the word thank
you for joining us we say once again and
we encourage you in the strongest
possible terms send in your questions no
questions no program well we don't have
to worry about that for quite a while
because we have any number of questions
we're asking you to send in more because
we can always use more you want to send
your questions to
TV at some
tv.org that is TV at some s-u-m as in
Mary
tv.org and we will answer them just as
soon as we can we are pleased to know
that so many of you have questions that
come in from around the world good for
us maybe not quite as good for you
because we don't get to all of the
questions as quickly as we'd like to
because we want to take time with each
question to make sure that we spend the
requisite amount of time answering your
questions when you send in when you take
time to send in a question we want to
stay with it and answer it from the word
of God and that is the promise that we
always make to you that we will answer
your questions from the word of God so
send them in and we will try to get to
them we encourage you when you send in
your questions if you would tell us
where you were writing from that would
help us so very very much because it
lets us know where our footprint is but
more than that it lets us know that
we're being a blessing across this broad
Earth and that men and women are being
encouraged uh from around the world and
we ask you to do that and thank you in
advance for doing that for us Pastor
Bohr if you would uh
ask the Lord's blessing on this
particular program we will begin sure
Our Father in heaven we come to you with
humility
knowing that our knowledge is so limited
compared to your infinite knowledge
and we have many questions many of them
we are not able to answer because they
involve Mysteries
but we thank you that there are many
questions that we can answer through the
power of your holy spirit so we ask that
as we begin this program that your holy
spirit will be with us to Enlighten us
give us the right answers to the
questions and bless those who are
watching this program we pray in Jesus
name amen amen and amen
all right our first question comes from
a Seventh-Day Adventist Pastor in South
Africa his name is Kevin and I'm gonna
leave out a little of the identifying
information that he puts here because of
the nature of the question but we want
to get right to it I've been recently
recruited to work in one of the
districts within this particular
conference
the challenge that I have encountered
recently is that in one of the churches
that I'm pastoring there there are men I
suppose including the personal
Ministries leader who believes that
women should not be allowed to preach
because the Bible uh because it's not
biblical to do so my question then is is
that quite true our woman irrespective
of circumstances uh not allowed to
preach from the platform and why
that's his question
well there were many women
who preached in the history of early
adventism many of them were very
successful evangelists I might mention
and of course the woman who is best
known for her preaching was Ellen G
white herself and she preached in many
places all over the world
and so uh per se there's no problem with
women preaching the problem is with the
leadership role in the church in other
words occupying the position of a senior
pastor of a church
because uh basically the Bible tells us
that the leadership role in the church
as well as in the home
is the duty of a man of the male
and some people might think that that's
a very sexist you know very patriarchal
but that's what the Bible teaches that
the Elder should be the husband of one
wife
and he should rule his house and uh and
have his children in subjection and so
no problem with women preaching right
the problem is with women having the
leadership role in the church or even
with a denomination and I I think
pastors you know I mean obviously or
your fellow Pastor there in this place
in Africa South Africa he's concerned
with this position of this man who or
people who believe that a woman cannot
be allowed to preach but biblically
speaking as as they were mentioning and
there's several examples one of them uh
is Anna the prophetess she was she did
not depart from the temple says Luke
Chapter 2 36-38 and she would teach or
speak to all of them that that were
around her in this in the temple about
Jesus Christ so we can see that
biblically there is evidences of of
women preaching and teaching you know
even teaching as a matter of fact even
Paul in Philippians 4 2 and 3 speaks of
this fellow woman who serve minister
with him in God capacity what type of
work they did were not exactly sure but
he recognizes that gift of
ministering serving in the church
according to their functions according
to to their abilities so it's important
to understand that it's not there's
nothing that that you know that blocks
or prevents someone from teaching or
even preaching but the most important
thing that perhaps people use it against
you know to to use this concept is the
fact that is the role of aspass was
mentioning of a pastoral
a senior pastoral that is not biblically
uh sound for a woman but that does not
prevent a woman from using the pulpit if
she needs to I mean imagine white
preached several times many many times
and uh if they don't they don't believe
in the prophet well then you know
they're mistaken as well so
amen
Amen to mine the
official platform of the Adventist
Church now is not against women
preaching it's against the role of
Pastor now the
there there are some sociologists in our
midst who will tell you that uh that
prohibition is is just sociology it was
a Prohibition of the times there are
many ways that people try to twist and
turn and ring that around so you if you
want to find literature you'll find some
but I think everybody must be convinced
in their own mind and understand this
issue for themselves
um I did a meeting in Romania back in
2017 uh my wife did her own meeting as
did the wife of the General Conference
president who encouraged my wife to do
so because she was very hesitant that
was her first time and uh I mean there
was a lot of shaking and you know every
night before she went but she she got
through it and had baptisms to show for
it uh but my wife has never wanted to
never tried to never attempted to uh
take the role of Pastor or leader of
anything that's not that's not her
nature uh so
um there's a lot of people would have to
apologize if if women could not preach
they can do a great job for the Lord
amen in many many capacities you know
there's a text which is uh really
critically important when it comes to
this particular subject
um and it's found in First Corinthians
chapter 11 and verse 3.
and most people have no problems with
two-thirds of the verse they have
problems with one-third of the verse uh
it says there and by the way the context
indicates that this is talking about the
worship service it's the worship service
that's being discussed here and the
Apostle Paul wrote but I want you to
know that the head of every man is
Christ
so do we have a problem with that no no
of course not okay uh the head of the
woman is the man
we got problems with that right some do
I mean we don't yeah but many do yes
right and then the head of Christ is God
so do we have any issue with that not
the father being the head of Christ no
uh
the fact that the father is the head of
Christ
does not make Christ inferior as a
person he's a hundred percent God or
lesser it's a functional difference in
other words the son
takes the the leadership role of the
father in other words the son does what
the father says exactly and many people
have trouble with that they say well
hell no you Jesus has no reason to take
uh a secondary role because he's just as
much God as the father he needs to
demand his rights well you know that's
uh that's not a very uh a very holy
attitude I might say and so the sun
being subject to the father is a
functional difference
not a difference of person both are God
but the son suggests subjects himself to
the authority of the Father the man is
supposed to subject himself to the
authority of Christ and the woman is to
subject herself to the authority of the
man that's God's order and it's talking
about the worship service now in the
society today where everybody's talking
about Equity that doesn't fly very well
right but we go by what the Bible says
we don't go by what culture says and I
might mention one other thing my latest
newsletter article
deals with upward and downward mobility
and I show in that newsletter that
Christ has voluntarily subjected himself
to his father's Authority
since eternity passed
is now subject to the father During the
period of his Incarnation and will ever
be a first according to First
Corinthians 15 will ever be subject to
his father's Authority amen it doesn't
make him inferior no right you know when
we were at the Theology of ordination
study committee to which I belonged
uh the people who were uh were in favor
of women's ordination could never get
over this obstacle they said no if you
say that Jesus is subject to the father
he's inferior to the father if you say
that the woman is subject to the
authority of the man you're saying that
the woman is inferior to the man but no
such thing because Jesus says he who who
makes himself the last is the first
and he who humbles himself will be
exalted and so uh this is this is just
an issue that should not be a matter of
debate in The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church as far as I'm concerned amen they
shouldn't be and and as you mentioned
Pastor the thing is that it's probably
our own pers perceived ideas of what is
acceptable in culture what we think is
right uh should be actually submitted
and subject to what Authority the Bible
says and just submit his ideas and say
you know if I think this way by the
Bible clearly tells me the other way I
gotta go with what the Bible says and
it's not about being above somebody else
as you mentioned is about the roles the
functions and finding ourselves willing
to submit to the order of God that
brings a structure he knows best he
knows that our society functions well if
we follow his
he's leaving when we go away from that
we find ourselves in the chaos which we
are living today yeah as they've said
many headed beast is a monster that's
right
I would just like to add that this
differentiation between role and
function is not a fourth separation God
is not right forcing Christ he says uh
John 4 34 my meat
my food what I I desire is to do the
will of him that sent me so these are
two entities in perfect agreement for
the for the Salvation of mankind this is
how we choose to align ourselves
for this purpose and there there's no
fighting there's no clawing there's no
scratching there's no subjugation it's
an agreed Arrangement if I can use that
term because they're trying to
accomplish a goal and that goal of
course is a Salvation of you and me the
problem with today is that everybody's
scratching for rights and and and and
and we don't want to downplay that
because women ought to equal ought to
get equal pay for equal work those kinds
of things but but the the idea of role
and function uh is interwoven into this
discussion and you cannot wish it away
because you have some sociological
premise that says
um it doesn't look good it's the Optics
are bad well that's not that's not um uh
the way the Bible functions
you know we've been studying the book of
Ephesians this quarter
and uh in Ephesians 5 it says in verse
22 wives submit to your own husbands
as to the Lord
but then a little later on in verse 25
it says husbands love your wives
just as Christ also loved the church I
found that wives have no problem
submitting to their husband's Authority
if the husband loves them the problem is
that many men have become dictators
and they don't love their wife they they
want to beat them into submission either
either literally or figuratively
verbally and that's a reason why women
have rebelled against uh male Authority
is because of the behavior of the men so
God's ideal is that wise voluntarily
subject themselves to the authority of
their husbands because their husbands
love them and the passage says they love
them even to the point of being willing
to give up their lives for their wives
absolutely and so it's not an issue of
superiority and inferiority it's a it's
an issue of the order that God
established from before sin existed in
this world absolutely and just you know
I just reading this question you know
that the pastor is in facing there there
might be some men who are taking these
verses in the word of God to try to
force their Authority upon their wives
or spouses or to consider women as
inferior to them and that's completely
against what the Lord wants us to think
or or act upon so you know people that
called on to these views that a woman is
inferior should be uh truly you know
should be enlightened to understand that
that is actually not the way that Christ
describes us to be as husbands we are to
cherish them love them give our lives
for them and not you know prevent them
from sharing from teaching from even
preaching that's not how it works so
yeah this is sad because as as we
mentioned this is a Seventh-Day
Adventist pastor who's dealing with
church members who have this really
truncated idea of a woman's abilities uh
I I think there are some who don't even
think women can have the Holy Spirit uh
kind of thing
um uh they have things to say and God
has given them a perspective and things
to say and they should be allowed uh to
to say that so thank you gentlemen for
sure wrestling with with this issue and
pastor Kevin we pray for you and with
you that the Lord will open the eyes of
uh of those who really believe that
women have nothing to do with preaching
in the Church of God Amen already
um are we all number one of the next
group yes this is coming to us from
Linda again we don't have a location but
we will answer your question
we are taught in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church
Jesus entered the most holy place in the
Heavenly temple in 1844.
if the veil in the Earthly Temple was
torn from top to bottom when Christ died
on the cross why then will the Heavenly
Temple continue to exist
good question it's a good question
it's a good question
the tearing and I will start this off
indicated the cessation of the Earthly
Temple it did not
indicate the cessation of Christ's
mediatorial efforts in our behalf that
building
that had been the dwelling place of the
Lord cease to function as such when
Christ went to the Cross but there was
something else that the whole Sanctuary
service was indicative of
that is going on even now in the courts
of Glory that Christ is very much a part
of and that is why the the sanctuary
in heaven is functioning uh very much
even until this day uh having set that
Foundation I'll let you Brethren build
the scaffolding
well the bottom line is that the reason
why the veil of the temple was rent from
top to bottom
is that uh
God wanted to indicate that the types
and shadows of the Old Testament had
been fulfilled in Christ
in fact I have here a quotation from
Desire of Ages 756 and 757
uh where it says when the loud cry it is
finished came from the lips of Christ
the priests were officiating in the
temple it was the hour of the evening
sacrifice the lamb representing Christ
had been brought to be slain
clothed in his significant and beautiful
dress the priest stood with lifted knife
as did Abraham when he was about to slay
his son with intense interest the people
were looking on
but the Earth trembles and Quakes for
the Lord himself draws near
with a rending noise the inner veil of
the temple that's the temple the veil
between the holy and most holy place the
Intervale of the temple is torn from top
to bottom by an unseen hand throwing
open to the Gaze of the multitude a
place once filled with the presence of
God
in this place the Shekinah had dwelt so
it's the most holy place yes here God
had manifested his glory Above The Mercy
Seat no one but the high priest ever
lifted the veil separating this
apartment from the rest of the temple he
entered in once a year to make an
atonement for the sins of the people but
Lo this Veil is rent in Twain the most
holy place of the Earthly Sanctuary is
no longer sacred
and now here's the reaction all is
Terror and confusion the priest is about
to slay the victim but the knife drops
from his nerveless hand and the lamb
escapes type has met anti-type in the
death of the Son of God the great
sacrifice has been made the way into the
holiest is laid open a New and Living
Way is prepared for all
no longer needs sinful Sorrowing
Humanity await the coming of the high
priest henceforth the Savior was to
officiate as priest and advocate in the
heaven of Heavens amen it was as if a
living voice had spoken to the
worshipers there is now an end to all
sacrifices and offerings for sin so the
renting of the temple veil was an
indication that there were no more
offerings and no more sacrifices it did
not mean that Jesus did not have
additional functions to perform in the
most holy Place well said it points to
what he did at that particular moment
absolutely Hebrews 8 1-2 speaks of that
precisely Pastor as you mentioned he
says now of the things which we have
spoken that is the sun we have such a
high priest who said on the right hand
of the Throne of the Majesty in the
heavens a minister of the sanctuary and
of the true Tabernacle which the Lord
pitched and not men so if if if he was
to cease to to do the work I mean
essentially was to be destroyed or
nothing had to do with that after Christ
died then he would not have to be an
intercessor for us he could not be a
high priest he could not be right now
interested in for us during the Judgment
so it's important to understand that
there's a reason why Christ had to go to
the century in heaven to perform the
duties of a high priest in favor of
mankind in favor of for us in
intercession for us and that's why the
contemplary sanctuary has to continue to
exist to fulfill all that planet
Redemption and not just you know uh be a
I guess an idea in just a concept but
actually an experience for us through
Christ's intercession for us and the
fact is that after the Ascension of
Christ according to Revelation 4 and 5
Jesus was walking among the candlesticks
yeah and he had a sensor presenting the
prayers of the Saints so if the if the
sanctuary was no longer necessary what
is Jesus doing ministering the holy
place yes there's no reason yes
his work in the court was finished right
which is his death and his resurrection
but that doesn't mean that the entire
service of the sanctuary had come to an
end correctly yeah there are benefits
that accrued from that death and his
ministering those benefits now I've got
a quick reason From Desire of Ages page
166 the sacrificial service that had
pointed to Christ passed away but the
eyes of Ben were turned to the true
sacrifice for the sins of the world the
Earthly priesthood ceased but we looked
to Jesus the minister of a New Covenant
and to the blood of sprinkling that
speaketh better things than that of Abel
the way into the holiest of all was not
yet made manifest while as the first
Tabernacle was yet standing but Christ
being
come as and high priest of all good
things to come by a greater and more
perfect Tabernacle not made with hands
of course that's the Heavenly by his own
blood he entered in once into the holy
Place having obtained Eternal Redemption
for us so the sacrificial service is one
of the things that really is an an
Adventist addition to the realm of
systematic theology that really no other
Church preaches that's something that
that um uh we we have by the grace of
God mine from the word of God and it
lets us know exactly gentlemen what's
going on right now where we are in the
Stream of time what is happening and
what is going to happen and how it
happens if the Protestant world had a
real handle on the sanctuary service a
lot of the questions and a lot of the
preaching that I hear from time to time
would cease to exist because it it it it
it it it those questions are answered in
the sanctuary service because they only
focus on the cross
you know what is more important I I
often ask what is more important the
perfect life of Christ is death for sin
is resurrection his intercession
and his judgment which of those is the
most important they're all important
well the fact is it's like making a
smoothie if he doesn't live a perfect
life the sacrifice won't be accepted
yeah and if he doesn't resurrect he
can't intercede and if he can't
intercede there's no judgment and so
each function of Christ builds upon the
previous one yes and the The Genius of
the Adventist view is that we have a
global view of all of the steps of Jesus
Through The Sanctuary in solving the sin
problem absolutely and that's the thing
the world or the enemy Satan has tried
to take the minds of people of
Christians from that beautiful truth of
the century and they only put our
attention to one aspect the cross or the
Ascension not realizing that this
beautiful Plan of Redemption teaches us
how the Lord will deal with the same
problem and how we can face God during
the Judgment which is happening with the
confidence that our intercessor is
working in our behalf helping us to be
able to be declared holy and acceptably
for the Lord so it's important that you
know we realize that if we take away any
of these beliefs or any of this teaching
of the doctrine of the sanctuary we
really have a uh unbalanced gospel yeah
a faulty gospel yes you know a lack of
understanding of what Christ is doing
for us now
one of the things that says is that you
cannot be saved in your sins Christ is
ministering uh
for us in the sanctuary and and and
providing Grace uh and pardon
and strength to overcome sin so it does
wear this idea that you can just come
and love and live while you want to live
and you'll be fine but if you really
understand the sanctuary message and
what's happening right now even as we
speak you understand the call to
Holiness and the necessity of being holy
in Christ amen gentlemen well done a
question that is often asked and um uh
well answered again our time gets away
from us so fast we wish you God's grace
we wish you God's peace we look to see
again well next we are together God
bless you keep writing we'll answer in
the name of Jesus bye-bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign